the bills in the postseason to the
announcement on wednesday that he was
going to retire
and there's probably a story to be told
or maybe there isn't but we always
wonder we look maybe it'll get reported
at some point
was there a communication with the colts
as to a point you had made
whether or not the colts would say we'd
like to have you back
but given what's happening with the cap
next year the number's more like
18 million or 19 million not 25 million
right and were there phone calls
discreetly made to other teams to see
whether or not
other teams would be in the philip
rivers business if he decided to roll
the dice
in free agency i remember last year as
he became a free agent after leaving the
chargers
i thought there was a chance he wasn't
going to find
a clear-cut starting job and would have
to either compete
or take a backup role and would he do
that you rarely see
the franchise quarterback who does that
joe flacco one of the limited exceptions
who will hang around
as the number two guy on a depth chart
and make the paycheck that goes along
with it instead of walking off into the
sunset
i wonder whether or not some work was
done
to get rivers to come to the conclusion
it's not going to be as automatic for me
this year as it was last year i don't
want to go through that and i'm just
going to walk away i i
i would think there's some feel for the
situation
you know rivers again i think a pretty
realistic true to himself
in reality type of guy who could
probably see the writing on the wall a
little bit
he understands that they're damn there's
a lot of quarterbacks out there and free
agency in the draft this year
i also find him a guy i don't think he
just would want to go to any team or go
anywhere right at least that's just the
way he comes off to me
you know with his his family how many
people he has you know to worry about as
far as that situation but i always felt
like it was just
a few limited places that philip rivers
would go
and play football even last year i just
didn't think it would be like oh
wherever you know wherever he's just
gonna end up you know that made sense
the colts
you know he's not he didn't grow up too
far from that area as far as tennessee
alabama is concerned and then frank
reich was there we always heard the
rumors about nashville tennessee titans
and all that because he didn't grow up
far
from there so i guess what i'm saying is
i think the timing is right and i don't
think that a lot of teams would have
clamored for phillip rivers this year
and it would have been more the
situation like you're saying like hey
you can come here but we're only giving
you this money
and there's no guaranteed you know that
you're going to be the starting
quarterback i think that's
probably what he was facing this year it
may have just been a conversation then
with one team the colts what do you
think and let me know what you're
thinking right
so i can make my plans because remember
when he signed with the colts for a
one-year deal there was talk by him
eventually that he wanted to play
multiple years
and the colts envisioned at least
so they said publicly multiple years you
know you don't want to be disrespectful
you don't want to create an issue when
there otherwise
isn't one and if all of a sudden the
cults are saying we don't want this guy
next year or words to that effect
that can be a distraction to what you're
trying to do in the season that you're
currently
playing but do you think i feel for that
before the season was over from the
colts that there was no talk
about you know hey let's do another year
or anything like that
he seemed before the bills game before
week 17 the thought of retirement he
said was on his mind and this could be
my last game and i have thought about
that
so you know this must have been stewing
his brain and having
some feel for where the situation was
going to go don't you think
yeah at times though you hear players
say they don't want to be
distracted by anything like that but if
you're thinking about it and you don't
act on it it becomes more of a
distraction you can't you can't push
things completely out of your mind
right and the more you're thinking about
it the more of an issue it becomes
it's better to seek clarity if there's
something that's bothering you so as
november goes into december and you
start seeing what the planets are gonna
possibly align like and you start
hearing
carson wentz maybe to indianapolis you
know at some point
and all it takes is a phone call or a
text message to your agent to say can
you get in touch with chris ballard
and and just get an idea of what they're
thinking for next year because i got
plans to make and it's harder for me
than most people because i have a large
family i just want to have an idea
sooner rather than later whether or not
i'm going to be getting ready for a
season
where i'm going to be am i going to have
to go look for something else
is it time for me to coach high school
football is it time for me to pursue
opportunities for sunday or monday
broadcasting
i i think it's it's not unreasonable to
believe that a guy approaching 40 who
has so many different plates spinning in
his life
didn't reach out directly or indirectly
to get an idea
of what the colts wanted to do next year
if not during the season immediately
after but sometime in that window
especially once the wence
talks started right you're trying to
focus on getting your team to the
playoffs and maybe trying to get to a
super bowl
and everywhere you turn now you see this
speculation about carson wentz next year
hey folks just let me know where i stand
so i can i can pursue the
final games of this season with the
right mindset knowing this is the last
go around
i think there's value in that so i
wouldn't be surprised chris if
those conversations happen not just
after the loss to the bills but before
yeah i would agree i i would think
there's some conversation either with
him directly or his agent who got a feel
for the situation and
if it was the agent he relays it to
philip rivers
okay so now now the big question
right i mean philip rivers legend
is he a hall of famer i mean this is
this is one that's going to be a good
conversation i think and of course he
lacks
a super bowl win and that never never as
easy as a quarterback so what do you
think
i saw suggestions yesterday that given
that drew brees most likely is retiring
and the phillip rivers are retiring in
the same off-season
could they go in together first ballot
like steve young and dan marino remember
when they went in first ballot together
wasn't it the two of them that went in
together and i think it was both the
first ballot
i think it was yeah um i i no
there's no way i can't remember i i will
have to look it up we'll look it up
during a break actually we'll forget we
say that just to
move past it and then we'll forget all
about it and move on pete's looking it
up
pete just woke up before the show
started folks so part of his process of
waking up
is to look this up for us he claims he'd
been awake
we don't believe it based upon how his
voice sounds right voice sounded very
much like whoa
i woke up just before the show started
good thing
um but here's my theory on rivers he
doesn't get in first ballot
right and look chris he was never the
best quarterback in football
during his years in the nfl there was
never a year where it's like philip
rivers is the guy there's
always someone else there's always
multiple someone else's
right you had peyton manning and you had
tom brady and you had the end of brett
favre's career and you had ben
roethlisberger who won super bowls and
you had eli manning who won super bowls
from your draft class and you didn't i
think it's very difficult for philip
rivers to get in
in his first year or maybe second or
third year but here's what i believe is
gonna happen yeah
i think rivers is gonna get into
broadcasting and i think rivers is gonna
be great
and that is gonna help him get into the
hall of fame just like it helped john
madden get into the hall of fame because
john madden
all due respect based on his coaching
career didn't coach long enough didn't
achieve enough
but what happened years later beloved
john madden greatest nfl broadcaster of
all time
his name is plastered on the popular
video game
he's getting in the hall of fame that's
real and
the voters will harumph and say bo we
don't consider those things and i say to
that
bull bleep yes you do
you may not realize it you may not think
you do
but you do and if everyone loves philip
rivers
as a broadcaster that's helping phillip
rivers get into the hall of fame
eventually chris i guess so you're right
i mean i i you know there's another phil
i know in phil sims who you know had a
similar path like that and won a super
bowl and i don't know nobody's talking
about him with the hall of fame
but i hear your point it's very real you
know and i who knows with the hall of
fame i mean it's hard to tell what the
hell is the criteria and what is it
i mean brian urlocker got in the first
ballot hall of fame with
ray lewis i mean you and i know that had
should have never happened
they're not in the same stratosphere you
know i don't know tom flores isn't in
the super bowl he won two of them i mean
in the hall of fame he won two of them i
don't understand that either
i don't get it i think it's a good i
don't
you you raise a good question there and
i think i certainly think if he does
announce and is good at it which we
expect them to be and fun and colorful
and all that
that certainly will help his case you're
right i i do i
no matter what the voters say or
anything at the very least maybe you get
into some sort of contributor or
something like that a guy who's been
around football forever yeah
but no but but they'll put him in
they'll put him in as a player they're
not going to burn the spot for a
contributor category they'll put him in
as a player
because he's got look he's retiring
fifth all time in yards
nothing though it means nothing it just
means nothing to me at this point i mean
you know again the the way the league is
set up everybody's gonna have numbers
like this in a few years
everybody it's it just doesn't matter
you know we've talked about this before
we can watch games and watch
quarterbacks never throw the ball past
the line of scrimmage and they're
they're seven for eight for a hundred
yards
oh what what oh he's on fire today oh
yeah is he he hasn't thrown a ball yet
but he's got 100 yards
you know passing i i don't know i think
he's a legend
i don't think he gets into the hall of
fame as much as i
want it to happen because i like the guy
and i think he embodies a lot
of what an nfl hall of fame player is
about
i still think it's just going to be
stats and not enough marquee
wins and big moments that i think is
ultimately going to hurt him
you know what what is his marquee
playoff game win
of course he never even got into a super
bowl but what does the marquee play off
win
you know the one where he tore his acl
and billy valdick came in and finished
the game right i mean it's hard to
really
say so that and then to what you kind of
say mike i don't think there was ever a
year
where we said philip rivers is one of
the three best quarterbacks in football
and again you tell me and correct me as
i go here maybe some years where we
thought he was dancing around the top
five
maybe i think right if we're being kind
but i don't even know if we can ever
really say it was
top five he was maybe right on the
outside looking in on some of his best
years at least that's how i feel i don't
what about you
i think his marquee playoff win would
have been
the game against the patriots at home in
the divisional round
2006 marlon mccree makes the
interception that ice is the game and
then
fumbles it that would have been let's
get it back because
you know back in that era the chargers
matched up with the colts
incredibly well do a little research
yeah it's easily found they were
chargers had the colts number that that
defense bedeviled
peyton manning it was one of the reasons
why i used to lobby for ron rivera to be
a head coach
ideally with another team in the afc
south because ron rivera's defenses
did a pretty good number on peyton
manning
he got the ultimate revenge against ron
rivera and the panthers in super bowl
50.
but if if the chargers win that game
maybe they end up in the super bowl
that year yeah they would have hosted
the colts that i remember having that
conversation with tony dungy about
trying to engineer
your seed is it better to be the four
seed or the three seed and duddy said
it's always better to be higher
because you never know how it's going to
fall together and you're going to end up
hosting the afc championship game like
they did that year against the patriots
after the patriots beat the chargers
that was their year that was their
chance well that's where you work out
yeah you're right that's where
you know it that that's where it's hard
so we we can't really come up with one
and yet we can come up i could come up
with a few others to go
he was a quarterback on a team that was
better than the team he played in the
playoffs and lost
so i think that's going to hurt him
certainly i mean those some of those
chargers teams there at the end of the
drew brees era
and phillip rivers wow were they good i
mean that's why they got rid of drew
brees they thought they were the best
team in football and they didn't make
the playoffs
i mean that's really what it came down
to but it's going to be an interesting
combo and of course
he's going to be interesting right mike
because of the the other guys in his
draft class who are also
right i think big ben's a shoeing eli
i would say is going to get in i don't
think it's a first ballot type of thing
but because he's eli manning and like
you said he's won two super bowls and
you know the mannings know how to play
the game a little bit i would imagine he
gets in at one point so
rivers could be the guy that's kind of
on the outside looking in as far as this
is concerned
shereen williams and i were talking
about this last night how the lobbying
by peyton manning for eli will be
intense and my official position has
been and continues to be i'm not
interested in being a hall of fame
selector but the one area where i would
love it
is when peyton manning is trying to call
me up and kiss my butt to vote for eli
and i'm putting him off like peyton not
now i'm hating i'm busy
peyton i got things to do copy paste
copy paste snarky comment can you call
me later
just the idea just the i thank you just
the idea that
peyton manning is trying to get you to
do something for him
and that's how it goes it is very
political and there is lobbying and i
guarantee you peyton manning is going to
call
all 48 of the selectors repeatedly
to sing the praises of his kid brother
and argue why he should get in that year
i guarantee you and i think eventually
people just going to say peyton i'll
vote for him if it means you will leave
me the hell alone
i'm telling you that's what's coming and
it's four years away i want to push back
on one thing you said though okay
because i agree with you
in his class he's behind roethlisberger
and eli manning right for a spot in the
hall of fame
they got multiple super bowl wins and
eli's got multiple super bowl mvps ben's
got
zero zero right or you could argue one
of the reasons they lost super bowl 45
is that bruce erin's and ben
roethlisberger they're
trying to get ben the mvp award more
than they were trying to win the game
frankly and there are people who are on
that team who believe that right
frankly so uh as a little a little dash
too
well hey that mvp conversation annoys me
anyways that that just
with these three quarterbacks you know
first off we could easily give big ben
the the mvp
conversation for the the cardinals game
the clutch
drive how they did that you know eli got
a
eli got an mvp because of one drive in
one of those
so one of the defenders should have been
the mvp of the first super bowl but the
quarterback of course always gets
favored in those things too so
that's become a little subjective and
annoying uh as well as we we talked
about
it's manning it's manning yeah that's
the point right the fact that he got
both of those mvps it's manning
you could argue david tyree should have
been the mvp of that game for making the
catch that we've never seen before and
haven't seen
since off of his helmet while rodney
harrison is dragging him down
folks you have any idea how difficult
that would be with rodney harrison
dragging him into the ground right to
hold on
damn football he's made of steel like i
don't know i mean he really is even at
47 or 8 whatever he is he still made a
steal i wouldn't fight rodney if you
paid me
i want to push back though against the
the flippant
reaction that you had to philip rivers
being fifth all time in passing yardage
because i'm looking
at the numbers here and you're saying
he's eventually going to be passed by
it's going to take a while
because i'm going down the list i don't
see who's going to catch him chris he's
ahead of dan marino
he's ahead of dan freaking mourinho and
and active quarterbacks matt ryan's got
8 000 yards to go
matt ryan undoubtedly will catch him
some of these other guys like matthew
stafford he's got a lot of work to do
he's 18 000 yards behind
philip rivers 18 000 yards three
a year it's it's you're getting into
that kind of conversation that's right
but i'm looking down here the active
list of guys who have a chance to catch
him
it's all guys who are older russell
wilson still got
30 000 yards to go he's at 33.
who was this one nine seasons russell
wilson
wilson right yeah so uh you know you and
i'm scrolling and i'm scrolling here's
kirk cousins at 28
000. hey listen the numbers are
impressive but you know it did that just
doesn't
vinnie testaverdi drew bledsoe they they
retired in the top eight
all-time in passing yards when they you
know again i think it's kind of the same
sort of talk and i'm not saying i think
philip rovers is better than those two
guys
but i i don't know if that necessarily
translates to
you know getting i don't think vinnie
testa verdi i don't think vinnie tessa
verdi was it was he in the top eight
oh here he is he's 15th now he's 15th
now
yeah football historian wow well 46 000
passing yards in a career that spanned
20 years right one of the quietest
great nfl quarterback careers that you
could ever see
but uh yeah look there he is at number
five phillip rivers and he will be
passed eventually and he'll be
you know nine or ten before too long uh
i i i
i just think based upon what we saw from
john madden what we saw as pete
mentioned i think we talked about this
last night on pftpm how dick lebeau got
into the hall of fame
as a player even though it was his
legend as an assistant coach
that got him over the top oh we didn't
consider that oh
okay sure you didn't hall of fame voters
you don't consider
all the things that you're not supposed
to consider fine
yeah you do you do and they did with
lebeau they did with madden and they
will with philip rivers and he's getting
in at some point
by virtue of the added boost that will
come from being a broadcaster if he does
it i'm still not sure he's going to do
it
i think he might say that garment shoot
i'm going to coach
football in high school and dad garment
shoot darn i'm not doing
monday night or sunday football or
whatever how how do you do both jobs
to the best of your ability right if
you're you can't just do drive-by
broadcasting
and just say hey you know i'm going to
do this job as long as you understand
that
i'm just showing up for the games i'll
watch the film
uh on on the plane to wherever the game
is but
i'm not making this my full-time job my
full-time job is coaching high school
football i just think it'll work
for a guy like that who seems like he's
going to be true to whatever he does
right i don't think he's going to do
anything half-assed no i agree
half-assed yeah well you said it it's
too late you've said it three times now
yes yeah
but no i'm with you i don't think he's
gonna try to you know do two things
half you know half ass like you said
it's gonna be one thing full
go all my attention and he's gonna be
mentally and physically and emotionally
invested into that that just seems to be
the guy he is
that's why you know he was fun to watch
and watch him talk crap and
yell at defensive players you don't see
that from quarterbacks that was really
the cool thing about phillip rivers
like who was it at first when he was in
the nfl was
jay cutler and the broncos who used to
like kind of get in their face and talk
and yeah all that i mean we never really
saw that out of the quarterback position
until phillip rivers and i mean we still
don't really see it very unique by him
one last thing before we move on i was
so impressed that you knew that vinnie
tessa verdi retired sixth all time until
i look at the sheets
in this giant blue background
is the note from pete that vinnie testa
verdi with sixth all time
i'm still a historian i thought you knew
it off the top of your head
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports